y te quiero contar algo que descubrí
practicando uno de mis pasatiempos
favoritos los mandalas te presento uno
que hice hace poquito los mandalas son
imágenes compuestas por varias figuras
de diversos tamaños y formas tenemos
círculos líneas
flechas y otras figuras más que se van
formando poco a poco a mí me gustan
mucho porque me ayudan a concentrarme
pero lo más interesante es que he podido
conocer mejor las sucesiones y los
patrones que se pueden encontrar en
ellas vamos a ver las sucesiones
compuestas que son aquellas que pueden
tener más de una sucesión o más de un
patrón en una sola figura o serie
numérica observa la siguiente imagen
vamos a hacerlo juntos el primer patrón
lo encontramos en los rombos veamos la
relación empecemos por aquí con los
rombos rojos tenemos un rombo rojo un
rombo azul
un rombo rojo dos rombos azules uno y
dos un rombo rojo tres rombos azules
aquí los puedes ver 1 2 y 3
un rombo rojo cuatro rojos azules 12
y 4 un rombo rojo 5 rojos azules 1 2 3
4 y 5 terminamos en esta secuencia
podemos establecer una regla que nos
dice que por cada rombo rojo que integre
la secuencia se agregará un rombo azul
podemos ver más patrones en la secuencia
de triángulos la voy a representar con
números para que sea más fácil en este
ejemplo hay dos tipos de triángulos
verdes y amarillos
vamos a empezar por los verdes
primero vemos que nuestra sucesión
comienza con un triángulo y después
siguen 2
en seguida y 3
luego 4
y por último hay 5 más
listo si la representamos numéricamente
nuestra sucesión quedaría así 1 2
4 y 5
en esta secuencia se puede ver que los
triángulos aumentan de uno en uno así
que esta es la regla o patrón para los
triángulos verdes muy fácil ahora vamos
con los amarillos aquí tenemos uno le
sigue en otros tres continuamos con
cinco después siete
y finalmente nueve triángulos amarillos
vamos a representar la sucesión con
números y quedaría de la siguiente
manera
1 3579 para esta sucesión la regla que
encontramos es la suma de dos en dos
terminamos recuerda que las sucesiones
compuestas son aquellas que al
intercalarse entre sí dan origen a
patrones que pueden formar otros más tal
como lo vimos en el mandala que
revisamos busca a tu alrededor en qué
otros lugares podemos encontrar
sucesiones compuestas